every night almost everyone on the
planet enters into a state of
unconsciousness and paralysis but what
is really happening inside the body when
we drift off and what's the impact if we
don't get enough sleep sleep is
regulated by your circadian rhythm or
body clock located in the brain the body
clock responds to light keys ramping up
production of the hormone melatonin at
night and switching it off when it
senses light there are four stages of
sleep that the body experiences in
cycles throughout the night on a good
night we cycle through these stages four
or five times
stages one and two are light sleep this
is a transition from being awake to
falling asleep
heart rate and breathing begin to slow
body temperature falls and muscles may
twitch
stage 3 is sometimes referred to as
Delta sleep because of the slow Delta
brainwaves that are released during the
stage this is the first stage of deep
sleep where our cells produce the most
growth hormone to service bones and
muscles allowing the body to repair
itself stage 4 is where we begin to
dream the body creates chemicals that
render it temporarily paralyzed so that
we do not act out our dreams
in this stage the brain is extremely
active
and our eyes although closed dark back
and forth as if we were awake
humans roughly spend one third of their
lives asleep modern lifestyles stress
and the proliferation of Technology mean
that people is sleeping far less today
than they were a century ago sleeping
less than seven hours per day is
associated with an increased risk of
developing chronic conditions which
could reduce life expectancy
so for a healthier longer life get some
shut-eye
you